et avec nous aujourd'hui pour ce club
Arnaud Benedetti bonjour Arnaud merci
d'être avec nous avec ton chef de la
revue politique et parlementaire le
politologue Pascal Perrine au bonjour
Pascal merci beaucoup d'être là et
Quentin nous a rejoint on va revenir
avec vous dans ce club sur l'attaque au
couteau d'Annecy Emmanuel et Brigitte
Macron qui se rendent ce matin en
Haute-Savoie l'émotion et les questions
lancées très vite peut-être trop vite
hier par une partie de la classe
politique sur les règles migratoires au
sein de l'Union européenne on va en
parler et puis un drame qui a raisonné
jusque dans l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
les débats sur la proposition de loi du
groupe yote qui visait à abroger la
réforme des retraites ont été stoppés
liottes à retirer son texte est-ce pour
autant la fin de la bataille politique
vous nous direz ce que vous en pensez on
commence ce club en allant du côté de la
Haute-Savoie
[Musique]
et la qualité c'est bien sûr cette
attaque au couteau hier à Annecy on va
aller en Haute-Savoie retrouver Cyril
pelva bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous vous êtes sénateurs de la
Haute-Savoie à trachée au groupe les
républicains vous êtes rendus hier très
vite à Annecy l'émotion l'imagine série
pelva et est encore vide ce matin
oui bien sûr l'émotion est encore vive
ce matin sachant qu'on a toujours les
enfants qui sont hospitalisés et les
deux adultes donc on attend d'avoir des
des nouvelles et rassurantes sur le état
de santé
vous n'avez pas vous n'avez pas de
nouvelles à l'heure actuelle sur l'état
de santé des victimes et peut-être de
nouvelles informations sur l'enquête
également
non actuellement j'ai pas de nouvelles
informations donc par la suite je vais
me rendre en préfecture dans la matinée
je vous l'avais dit le président est le
président est annoncé il y avait je
crois également le ministre d'éducation
nationale donc je pense qu'on aura
potentiellement des informations
plus récentes par rapport à ce qu'on
avait eu hier soir quand on était
présent au moment de l'arrivée de la
première ministre
Emmanuel et Brigitte Macron se rendent
ce matin
que le Président de la République
ben écoutez on va voir quel est le quel
est le temps qui sera à partir s'il
reçoit les parlementaires mais je pense
que aujourd'hui l'intérêt l'urgence
c'est vraiment d'avoir ce lien avec les
parents
les victimes et je pense qu'on attend du
président de la République qui soit aux
côtés justement de de victimes par an et
également des personnes qui sont
intervenues hier sur sur cette attaque
et Elisabeth borne est arrivé hier assez
rapidement sur les lieux avec ses côtés
Gérald Darmanin vous avez eu un échange
en préfecture il y avait Laurent
Wauquiez également le président de la
Région comment s'est passé cet échange
c'est un échange qui a été finalement
assez simple c'est à dire que Elisabeth
borne et Gérald Darmanin sont venus ils
ont fait le tour des lieux ont été
salués l'intégralité des services de
secours qui étaient présents des
pompiers etc donc il y a eu un temps qui
a été réservé en préfecture avec
finalement toutes ces personnes
ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'il y a eu
beaucoup beaucoup de retenues et
finalement les messages c'était un
message de remerciement remerciement
pour ce qui a été fait et puis saluer
l'action notamment des policiers
municipaux qui sont intervenus en trois
quatre minutes et qui ont permis
d'éviter un bain de sang il y a eu des
réactions politiques très rapidement
hier après l'annonce de ce drame
notamment du côté des républicains avec
des questions très vite posées sur la
politique migratoire est-ce que ces
réactions ont été trop rapides pour vous
oui j'ai l'occasion de m'exprimer chez
certains de vos confrères je trouve que
c'était c'était trop rapide on avait des
enfants qui étaient sur la table
d'opération
à l'hôpital à l'hôpital d'Annecy et tout
de suite on avait l'impression que le
procès était déjà fait les choses
étaient déjà faites alors même que nous
avions pas les éléments en notre
possession notamment sur la saillant sur
ce qui s'est passé parce que ce qu'il
faut voir c'est que la saillant était
comment dire en visite médicale donc on
savait pas du tout quelles étaient les
circonstances on savait pas du tout
qu'elle était son parcours on savait
juste qu'il venait qui venait d'être
Suède et finalement c'est au fur et à
mesure qu'on a vu tout ce qu'on a appris
tout ce qu'on a appris depuis et
d'ailleurs on a vu les républicains ont
retiré la conférence de presse et je
pense qu'il aurait fallu faire preuve de
plus de retenue à ce moment là
il y a une forme de récupération
politique selon vous de ce drame
je pense qu'on a voulu mettre peut-être
la charrue avant les bœufs et puis de
faire de faire passer des messages alors
que on voit que la réalité par rapport
au message initialement qui était prévu
et la réalité en tout cas de ce que nous
découvrent aujourd'hui et ben il y avait
il y avait un écart donc moi je regrette
vraiment c'est peut-être cette
instrumentalisation de ce qui s'est
passé Annecy et est vraiment on était
dans une période où on était dans
l'émotion dans le drame et je le redis
on avait des enfants qui étaient en
train de qui était en train de se faire
opérer qui était entre la vie à la mort
qui sont toujours entre la vie et la
mort et je pense qu'aujourd'hui on avait
plus besoin de messages rassurant on
avait besoin d'unités et on avait besoin
peut-être d'attendre un peu que la
température redescende pour regarder
quelle était la réalité d'essai et avoir
plus plus d'éléments ce qui est arrivé
un peu plus tard dans la journée merci
beaucoup Cyril pelvat merci d'avoir été
avec nous sénateurs de la Haute-Savoie
vous étiez évidemment présent très vite
hier sur les lieux de cette attaque
merci d'avoir été notre invité on va
revenir évidemment sur ce que dit à
Cyril pelvat sur la partie l'opération
politique mais on apprend ce matin
qu'Emmanuel et Brigitte Macron vont se
rendre sur place parce que c'est
important cette visite du chef de l'État
oui tout à fait c'est important et
j'allais dire ça coule de source c'est
nécessaire
le président de la République représente
bien sûr le principe d'unité d'unité de
la nation et devant un tel drame une
telle horreur on n'a jamais vu
j'allais dire un massacre d'enfants de
de ce type ou une tentative de ce type
c'est littéralement monstrueux il faut
en effet que la réaction soit la hauteur
du défi qui est lancé et que le
président Vienne s'enquérir au plus près
des victimes et des familles des
victimes ça me semble couler de source
d'autre part il faut distinguer les
temps là je crois que on est dans le
temps du du recueillement ce qui ne veut
pas dire qu'il y aura par la suite il
doit y avoir un temps du débat et le
trouble qui est né hier
est dû au fait que voilà le temps du
débat fortement chevauché le temps du
recueillement mais cela ne doit pas dire
que voilà il ne faut pas poser des
questions qui peuvent être des questions
dérangeantes dans les dans la semaine
qui vient et qui ont été très vite
posées par une partie de la classe
politique hier Arnaud notamment sur la
politique migratoire sur une immigration
massive c'est ce qu'on dit certains
dirigeants politiques est-ce que ces
réactions ont été trop rapides
vous savez je ne suis pas sûr que par le
passé les réactions n'est pas été
n'étaient pas plus rapide par rapport à
un certain nombre un certain nombre
d'événements qui sidéraient l'opinion
elle était peut-être elle était tout
autant sauf que la différence
fondamentale c'est que la caisse de
résonance aujourd'hui d'amplification et
beaucoup plus forte donc en effet ça
interroge aussi ce type d'événement par
de là l'émotion légitime que ça provoque
dans la classe politique dans l'opinion
publique en général parce que sans
prendre à des enfants c'est un acte de
barbarie absolue c'est pas aussi
malheureusement
j'allais dire nouveau rappel qu'en 2012
Mohamed Merah a assassiné de sang-froid
un certain nombre d'enfants parce qu'ils
étaient juifs dans des conditions
absolument épouvantables mais ça
interroge notre capacité justement à
être en distance par rapport à
l'événement c'est-à-dire être capable à
un moment donné de garder malgré
l'émotion une forme de sang de réfléchir
l'événement et ça a été rage bien
évidemment la capacité des responsables
politiques être en mesure finalement de
d'orchestrer un débat qui soit un débat
qui
mystérise pas encore plus une société
qui l'est beaucoup plus qu'il est
toujours un peu plus donc ça c'est vrai
que c'est un vrai sujet ensuite
évidemment on a vu très rapidement
certaines ondes de questions
d'opinion s'exprimer sur la
responsabilité éventuelle de notre
politique migratoire dans ce drame je
crois qu'il est aujourd'hui à ce stade
vraiment trop tôt pour exprimer une
quelconque que je veux dire analyse un
tant soit peu sérieuse mais je suis je
rejoins ce que dit Pascal Perrineau il
faut qu'il y ait débat on ne peut pas si
vous voulez un moment donné neutraliser
seulement parce que il y a une émotion
légitime qui se manifeste parce qu'il
faut qu'il y ait un besoin de
rassemblement et de solidarité tout à
fait légitime on peut pas neutraliser le
débat autour de la police
sur les finalement les les mécanismes et
les déterminants qui amènent à ce type
de drame donc éventuellement aussi en
effet sur notre politique migratoires et
Quentin on va parler de ce sujet parce
qu'on en a appris hier un peu plus sur
le profil de cette assaillance et vous
allez nous en dire plus
suédoise il avait un enfant de 3 ans
dans ce pays en Suède en novembre 2022
il a fait une demande d'asile à l'Office
français de protection des réfugiés des
appâts d'un lofpra mais c'était sans
objet puisqu'il avait déjà le statut de
réfugiés c'est ce qui a expliqué
Isabelle dans le point presse hier
qu'elle a fait à Annecy et ayant le
statut de réfugié syrien en Suède en
fait il pouvait se déplacer librement
dans l'espace Schengen on le rappelle
l'espace Schengen qui abolit depuis 1995
les frontières vous le voyez entre les
entre les 27 pays de cet espace
certains sont membres de l'Union
européenne
à tous et donc c'est donc cette règle
qui a fait que il pouvait se déplacer et
les questions migratoires étaient au
coeur d'un sommet justement qui se
tenait hier à Luxembourg entre les
ministres de l'intérieur de l'Union
européenne oui en fait il faut le savoir
depuis 3 ans la Commission européenne
tente de faire passer une réforme de
l'asile et de l'immigration entre les
États membres de l'Union européenne
cette réunion de l'UE a été considérée
hier comme un moment clé cela était un
marathon il nous reste peut-être 100
mètres déclarer hier à la Commission
européenne aux affaires intérieures et
Yves là Johnson un plan les États
membres à faire ces derniers mètres pour
arriver un accord je cite alors Gérald
Darmanin que l'on voit sur les images au
début du sommet du précipitamment
quitter la réunion suite aux événements
d'Annecy qu'y a-t-il dans cette réforme
européenne Quentin la Commission
européenne a dévoilé ce nouveau pacte
sur la migration et l'asile en septembre
2020 et on le voit Ursula Venen qui
porte un masque c'était le contexte bien
sûr de la conte de l'épidémie à l'époque
c'est ce plan qui donc à fait hier soir
l'objet d'un accord à Luxembourg entre
ministre de l'intérieur on va voir ce
qu'il y a dans cette réforme avec une
animation cette réforme vise à durcir
les renvois de migrants irréguliers et
mettre en place des contrôles accrus aux
frontières extérieures ils vise à créer
des procédures accélérées surtout pour
les sorties les ressortissants ou et
bien les pays ont été dans les demandes
d'asile ont été refusés et surtout une
en place un mécanisme de solidarité
entre les États membres et on le sait
c'est une compétence l'immigration qui
est partagée entre les États membres
entre les États et l'Union européenne de
la difficulté à trouver un accord en
fait depuis 2020 sur ce pacte il y a
trois visions de pays dans ce dossier
d'un côté les pays d'Europe centrale
opposés à ce pacte c'est le groupe de
vis de grade Hongrie Pologne Slovaquie
République tchèque que l'on voit à
l'image de l'autre côté des amendes en
première ligne dans ce dossier la Grèce
l'Italie l'Espagne qui veulent plus de
solidarité au milieu
il y a troisième groupe dont on fait
partie la France qui tente de trouver un
compromis Pascal Perrineau coïncidence
du calendrier hier les milliers de
l'intérieur étaient réunis et un premier
accord a été trouvé est-ce que cet acte
repose avec assiduité en France la
question de la politique migratoire
européenne si vous voulez en France le
problème c'est que
indépendamment de ce qui se passe au
plan européen dans le rapport avec
l'opinion publique deux choses si vous
voulez on voit d'abord que l'enjeu
migratoire et pour les Français une
vraie question et deuxièmement ils ont
l'impression que depuis allez des années
mais peut-être des décennies il n'y a
pas de politique migratoire française
que ce soit la droite ou la gauche le
pays aussi mais qu'il n'y a pas de
véritable politique migratoire qu'elle
soit ferme ou dites ouvertes qu'il n'y a
pas de politique migratoire donc
indépendamment des négociations au plan
européen qui sont importantes se posent
le problème pour l'actuel pouvoir d'être
porteur une réelle politique migratoire
et non pas j'allais dire d'une xiem d'un
XM projet de loi de plus qui ne définira
pas de manière claire une politique
migratoire sinon on risque d'avoir un
gros problème c'est que autour de
multiples affaires
à nouveau le débat migratoire devienne
un débats central à la société française
dans le climat que décrivait tout à
l'heure Arnaud Benedetti qui est un
climat parfois dystérisation extrêmement
forte particulièrement autour de ce type
d'enjeu donc il vaut mieux prévenir que
guérir en la matière il vaut mieux
prévenir et là le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est que pour l'instant nous
n'avons pas une classe politique
française qui est à la hauteur du défi
il y a le sujet européen le sujet
français moi je pense que l'Union
européenne joue en partie sa survie sur
la question migratoire on l'avait pensé
pendant des années que c'est sur les
questions économiques ou la question
monétaire et on voit bien ça a été
parfaitement décrit on voit bien qu'il y
a aujourd'hui des désaccords entre les
États membres de l'Union européenne en
raison d'histoire et de culture
différente l'Europe centrale n'a
vraisemblablement en tout cas les
dirigeants de l'Europe centrale n'ont
vraisemment pas les mêmes positions que
parfois les dirigeants français donc ça
c'est un sujet qui est absolument à mon
sens essentiel et qu'il y a une course
de vitesse entre les opinions publiques
et les dirigeants européens parce que
quand même la réalité de l'opinion
publique en France et en Europe c'est
une opinion publique qui d'une certaine
manière demande des politiques de
fermeté en matière aujourd'hui de
politique de régulation migratoire et en
France le sujet est finalement il existe
de manière j'allais dire visible dans
l'espace politique depuis le début des
années 1980 pour aller très vite et
notamment avec le surgissement du Front
national à partir du début des années 80
donc ça c'est une c'est une question qui
à mon avis essentielle et c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui une partie de l'opinion
publique considère que tous les pouvoirs
politiques depuis 30 ans ou depuis 40
ans n'ont pas été en mesure de régler et
d'apporter des solutions à cette à ce à
ce problème là va donner du grain à
moudre républicain qui disait qu'il faut
faire primer le droit national sur le
droit européen en matière migratoire il
peut y avoir un espace c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que les dirigeants des
républicains ont pris à bras le corps ce
problème migratoire avec deux
propositions de loi tout à fait avec
deux propositions de loi et la tentative
de définir en effet une politique qui
est une politique en effet de de fermeté
cependant est-ce que ça sera suffisant
pour les faire véritablement réexister
c'est une autre affaire et on va voir
que cette attaque d'Annecy a résonné
jusque dans l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
nationale où les députés et examinaient
la proposition loi du complot sur
l'abrogation des 64 ans les débats ont
été stoppés Gaspard flamand
hier en pleine fin de partie contre la
réforme des retraites l'Assemblée
nationale observe une minute de silence
après l'attaque au couteau survenu à
Annecy
après cette attaque les députés
Renaissance dénoncent des débats en
décalage avec le drame qui vient de se
dérouler par la voie de leur président
Aurore berger on a envie de vous dire
que être en ce moment dans l'hémicycle
avec une espèce de bataille de
chiffonniers sur une recevabilité au nom
d'amendement nous paraît en totale
décalage par rapport à l'effroi qui à
mon avis submerge notre pays les
oppositions dénoncent tout de suite la
récupération de ce drame par la majorité
plutôt dans l'hémicycle les débats sur
la réforme des retraites ont été agitées
le ministre du Travail décrit une
proposition de loi du groupe liote
presque ni liste et vide vous ne propos
ez parce que vous n'avez pas de projet
alternatif commun puis les députés
d'opposition hausse le ton et mettent en
avant le mépris du Parlement et de la
démocratie par le gouvernement le groupe
liote finit par retirer sa proposition
de loi vider de son sang selon eux il ne
reste plus rien et vous l'avez compris
dans le texte que nous avons prononcé
présenté sauf évidemment les amendements
de la minorité présidentielle les élus
de la nuque annoncent te déposer une
motion de censure on peut pas banaliser
ce qui a eu lieu hier et le seul outil
parlementaire que nous avons pour le
dramatiser au sens positif du mot c'est
à dire qu'il y a une discussion qui a un
moment là-dessus que nous puissions à
l'occasion de celles et ceux qui portant
notre parole monter à la tribune dire
pourquoi nous le faisons je veux que les
Françaises et les Français entendent
quel est le problème le groupe idiote
n'a pas encore annoncé s'il souhaitait
rejoindre cette notion de censure de la
gauche on va parler de la bataille
politique contre la réforme de traite
mais on a entendu Alexis Corbière très
critique il était notre invité il y a
quelques minutes sur le faire qu'hier
aur est sorti de l'hémicycle en plein
débat sur la proposition de la du groupe
lot pour dire que les débats étaient
décalés avec la taxe d'Annecy et dire
qu'il y avait une forme de récupération
politique de la part de la présidente du
groupe Renaissance est-ce qu'on peut y
voir ça ou pas Arnaud
c'est une déclaration qui peut
apparaître elle-même décalé d'une
certaine manière
par rapport à ce qu'on attend justement
de responsable politique je pense qu'en
effet il faut pas instrumentaliser d'une
certaine manière le drame d'hier
sur un plan j'allais dire politique et
de la même manière il ne faut pas
instrumentaliser ce drame pour
démonétiser ce qui était en train de se
passer à l'intérieur de l'hémicycle
c'est-à-dire la discussion d'une
proposition de loi dans le cadre d'une
niche parlementaire je crois que la
confusion et le pire service que l'on
puisse rendre à la parole publique et à
l'exercice des responsabilités
politiques et Madame berger à mon avis a
commis une erreur et d'ailleurs cette
erreur a été unanimement dénoncé par
l'ensemble de la classe politique et je
pense que même à l'intérieur de la
majorité ces déclarations du gêné
vraisemblablement parce que c'est cette
confusion qui d'une certaine manière
entretient aussi ce climat politique un
peu un peu délétère vous partagez oui
c'est passé hier matin à l'Assemblée il
faut pas mélanger j'allais dire déjà les
Français ont énormément à se repérer et
la véritablement on est au sommet de la
confusion on mélange des questions des
enjeux qui n'ont rien à voir on
interrompt le processus du travail
parlementaire en faisant intervenir
cet événement dramatique d'Annecy et on
abîme beaucoup la perception du débat
parlementaire sur le fond en revanche on
s'aperçoit une fois de plus que les
oppositions sont en fait des oppositions
fondamentales sur les règles du jeu en
écoutant d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
Alexis Corbière c'est-à-dire au fond là
et les filles toute une partie de la
nupesse se sent maintenant à nouveau
très mal à l'aise dans les institutions
de la 5e République voilà et il propose
en effet d'en changer et pour eux la
porte de sortie quand on écoute Alexis
Corbière tout à l'heure c'est la Sixième
République c'est une assemblée
constituante etc on retombe dans un
travers très français quand les choses
ne vont pas qu'est-ce qu'on fait mais on
change de constitution ça a amené
d'ailleurs cet instabilité phénoménale
de nos institutions tout au long du 19e
et du 20e est-ce la solution je me
permets dans d'en douter mais est-ce que
ce qui s'est passé c'est ces derniers
jours ces dernières heures avec
elbronflée qui a finalement fait le
choix d'activer l'article 40 pour
empêcher un débat et un vote sur
labrogation des 64 ans finalement ça va
renforcer quelque part l'anti
parlementarisme c'est ce que nous disait
Alexis Corbières je ne suis pas sûr je
ne suis pas sûr parce que quand vous
regardez d'ailleurs les études d'opinion
et positionnement d'une majorité de nos
concitoyens ne serait-ce que sur ce
sujet de la proposition de loi des jeux
posés par le groupe liotte une majorité
de Français considérée qu'il fallait que
cette proposition de loi soit discutée à
l'Assemblée nationale alors on peut
ensuite parler pendant des heures et des
heures de la constitutionnalité ou de
l'anticonstitutionnalité de ce
dispositif les deux interprétations sur
le fond sont vraisemblablement audible
il y a vraiment une interprétation très
littérale de l'article 40 par l'exécutif
ce qui ne se faisait pas par le passé
mais qui correspond en effet d'une
certaine manière si ce n'est à l'esprit
mais à la lettre de la Constitution et
puis ceux qui aujourd'hui contestent
cette interprétation n'ont pas tout à
fait tort parce que il y a une pratique
qui était une pratique pour ce qui
concerne les propositions de loi dans le
cadre des niches parlementaires qui
étaient une pratique plutôt qui laissait
disons de de la latitude à l'examen de
complexe et ils ont pas tort quand ils
disent finalement si on applique
littéralement aujourd'hui
l'article 40 on ne pourra plus discuter
une seule proposition de loi dans le
cadre des niches parlementaires donc les
deux finalement version sont audibles la
réalité c'est que je pense que c'est ça
le plus important c'est que l'Assemblée
nationale qui a été élu en 2022 est une
Assemblée nationale que les Français ont
voulu comme une Assemblée nationale de
contre-pouvoirs au président de la
République et la pratique du président
de la République depuis un an et de
considérer qu'il a un mandat du peuple
français sauf que le franc le peuple
français à travers ce représentant lui
dit mais ce n'est pas tout à fait le
mandat que vous imaginez avoir il y a
des est-ce que désormais la bataille
politique et parlementaire est terminée
sur cette réforme des retraites Pascale
il va y avoir la tentation à la fois au
plan politique et au plan syndical de
prolonger la ferme et on le voit bien
regardez les effectifs de la dernière
manifestation
c'est en train comme toujours de
s'étioler donc il y a un moment il y
aura nécessaire réflexion chez ceux qui
emmènent le mouvement de contestation
afin de savoir si le combat qui mène ne
devient pas un combat non pas
d'avant-garde mais derrière regarde avec
en plus de décrets d'applications de la
réforme qui sont en train de rentrer en
vigueur on en a deux sur les 31 au total
et qui bien ont déjà été publié au
Journal officiel c'était dimanche
dernier c'est exactement est-ce que ce
qui pourrait peut-être apparaître comme
une victoire politique d'Emmanuel Macron
on est vraiment une Arnaud est-ce que ça
ne va pas se transformer en crise
politique en crise démocratique en crise
institutionnelle
la question fondamentale c'est la suite
au Parlement je pense au delà de la
suite dans la rue nous verrons les
conséquences sociales que sauvera sur
les différents mouvements sociaux mais
c'est véritablement l'interrogation de
savoir si
l'exécutif va pouvoir tenir très
longtemps avec un etiage parlementaire
aussi faible et on est finalement tout
juste à un an du résultat de l'élection
législative de 2022 il reste quatre ans
quatre ans c'est long avec une majorité
aussi relative donc le sujet là et on va
avoir des juges de paix qui vont arriver
sur le plan des textes notamment la
question de l'immigration
à l'automne prochain à nouveau le budget
à la faire voter et une première
ministre si Madame borne est encore à
Matignon qui va devoir réutiliser 10
49,3 pour faire passer le budget dans un
contexte où le 49-3 est devenu le
symbole aussi de voilà de l'énervement
des Français contre la réforme des
retraites ça marque un tournant quand
même dans le
dans la pratique des institutions dans
ce que va pouvoir justement en tout cas
c'est une découverte par les Français du
fait que une majorité relative aussi
ténue dans un régime comme le régime de
la 5e République ça rend très difficile
l'exercice du pouvoir ça le rend pas
impossible ça fonctionne depuis un an
mais de là a fonctionné pendant 5 ans
comme ça ça risque d'énerver au sens
premier du terme énormément l'opinion
publique et la classe politique donc on
en revient toujours au même débat
c'est-à-dire est-ce qu'il ne faut pas
penser mais très sérieusement à
l'établissement d'une coalition
parlementaire
ayant une majorité absolue ou une
majorité relative plus confortable qui
permettent l'exercice du pouvoir donc
avec les républicains voilà avec les
républicains avec tout tout partie
républicain mais vous savez quand on
voit que textes sont déposés par l'IoT
mais moi je me disais quand au soir des
élections législatives voilà un petit
groupe qui vient de se créer qui est un
groupe idéal pour le moment venu et
élargir la majorité macronienne voilà et
les choses se sont totalement retournées
c'est ça ce qui est passionnant tiens
politique on est toujours surpris et on
continuera de l'être voilà on va prendre
peut-être un peu l'air dans cette
actualité politique qui est assez
chargée actualité tout court d'ailleurs
qui est assez lourde on va vous emmener
à roues en roue on se déroule la très
attendue armada les premiers bateaux
sont arrivés mercredi dernier
préparatifs sur lesquels une foule de
Badoo déjà fait le déplacement pour
saluer les équipages Marion Delpech
à quelques heures du coup d'envoi des
festivités il apparaît enfin à l'horizon
cette fois-ci ce n'est pas dans un film
de cinéma mais dans le port de Rouen que
l'étoile du roi subjugue avec ces trois
mains et son équipage cette réplique
d'encore sert à loin datant de 1745 est
une invitation aux rêves elle est
marrants ils voient le monde entier ils
font le tour du monde il s'arrête à
Rouen en Normandie ils viennent chez
nous c'est magnifique et ils ont plein
d'histoires à raconter parmi les
nouveaux arrivants démarrant mais aussi
des militaires venus à bord du crocus et
du m921 de navire de gar-belge en plein
accostage également les locaux de
l'étape partie de Fécamp à 70 km de là
avec ce langoustier entièrement
construit en bois construit en Bretagne
dans les années 60 on est quelques
années après la guerre il y avait qu'on
reconstruire les bateaux il y avait plus
d'acier il a construit des bateaux en
bois sur les modèles des bateaux qui se
faisaient avant guerre la seule
différence c'est qu'on mettait un gros
moteur et on mettait plus de voile donc
le bateau il a fait le bateau de pêche
il était langoustier donc il pêchait au
casier et oui bah il a été récupéré
réhabilité en bateau de plaisance sur 10
jours l'Armada de Rouen devrait
accueillir près de 6 millions de badauds
alors pour profiter des bateaux dans les
meilleures conditions certains ont leurs
petites astuces si on peut si on est
courageux j'allais dire d'arriver à 6
heures du matin tout le monde se
réveille enfin ils sont déjà réveillé
depuis un moment et il y a la vie on les
voit faire leur gym se réveiller enfin
c'est sympa oui oui alors que la foule
s'épaissit en quelques heures les
commerçants s'activent pour finir au
plus vite le montage de leur stand ici
c'est la destination de la Martinique
que l'on s'apprête à promouvoir mais
aussi des dégustations de Rome AOC c'est
un événement qui a attiré énormément de
monde qui est un événement très
convivial familial on espère que les
gens vont venir découvrir nos bons
produits de la Martinique à chaque
édition de l'Armada de Rouen les
organisateurs font en sorte de réserver
des surprises pour le public
et cette année si cette étrange voilier
cargo qui devrait être au centre de
toutes les attentions ok c'est un bateau
qu'on a tenu à faire venir puisque c'est
la conjonction donc de la voile de la
mer et aussi de l'empreinte
environnementale puisque c'est un cargo
à voile et donc il va faire des liaisons
Bordeaux la Guyane en transportant les
fusées Ariane et donc il va naviguer à
50% de son temps à la voile et 50% avec
des moteurs très économes donc c'est
c'est un bateau qui diminue son
emprunton environnemental par 4 à peu
près par rapport à un bateau classique
le futur de la navigation exposé au cœur
de cette fête maritime à la démarche
éco-responsable bruit de moteur et
plastique sont bannis du site cette
année pour assurer le bon déroulement de
l'Armada plus de 400 bénévoles sont déjà
sur le qui vivent dès demain avec le la
Journée mondiale de l'océan c'est 10
jours de folie des jours de d'animation
le département la région la ville la
métropole tout le monde est derrière
nous pour que cet événement soit aussi
fabuleux que les précédents une armada
qui s'ouvrait lors de la Journée
mondiale de l'océan
l'occasion de sensibiliser les visiteurs
à la protection de l'environnement et
voilà pour ces très jolies images de
Marion Delpech du côté de l'Armada de
Rouen la semaine prochaine on vous
emmène dans le parc des écrins ce sera
tout aussi beau Quentin regarde ce
qu'elle a une de la presse régionale
c'est parti
[Musique]
et Quentin la presse régionale revient
largement ce matin sur cette attaque à
une cire voilà les froid définition
grandes frayeur souvent mêlée d'horreur
ce matin c'est ce même mot et froid
toutes les rédactions de France parlent
de ce mot c'est le sentiment qu'il en
porte l'Alsace tous les titres du groupe
hébra Le Courrier de l'Ouest à Angers le
Dauphiné on va y revenir le Midi Libre à
Montpellier la montagne a
Clermont-Ferrand et froid et stupeur
quitte la nouvelle Républic à Tours à
Toulon même expression on le sait Oriane
c'est toujours le signe d'une émotion
intense dans le pays quand tous les
titres de France consacrent une à une
même information et on continue avec
d'autres expressions à la une de ces
journaux la Marseillaise dit le titre
avec ce mot abject Ouest-France choqué
moi regardez sud-ouest à Bordeaux
terreur et stupéfaction le Télégramme en
Bretagne horreur et choc national et
vous le disiez Quentin on va se pencher
plus particulièrement sur le Dauphiné un
c'est le journal la presse locale
d'Annecy et qui a recueilli des
témoignages de gens qui étaient présents
sur place lors de l'attaque j'ai vu une
maman récupérer un enfant raconte ainsi
une licenne présente sur place deux
classes étaient en fait réunies dans la
pelouse pour soit un cours de sport ou
pour fêter la fin de l'année avec un des
professeurs quand ils ont compris ce qui
était en train de se jouer autour d'eux
au début on a entendu des cris sembables
à ceux d'animaux on a cru que c'était
des oiseaux raconte la liste CN dans le
journal au bout d'un petit moment les
cris ont commencé à être plus terrifiant
là on a compris qu'il y avait quelque
chose de grave une cellule psychologique
a été mise en place pour ses lycéens qui
se disent sous le choc autre sujet la
une de la presse régionale c'est le
courrier
Picard change de sujet effectivement
mais c'est aussi très important retour à
la case sécheresse peut-on lire aller
une du journal pas une semaine Oriane
sans que la presse régionale me consacre
une une à ce problème dans les
départements la Picardie en plus touchée
par une sécheresse éclair phénomène qui
entraîne un assèchement rapide des sols
on termine avec un sujet plus léger
c'est vendredi
un sourire un peu quelque chose de voilà
pour un peu le changer le voilà le mood
qui est assez lourd en soi effectivement
elle vit aux amateurs de rugby Stade
Toulousain Racing 92 s'affront
aujourd'hui pour une place en finale du
Top 14 la finale c'est samedi prochain
Oriane 17 juin votre serviteur aura le
plaisir d'y assister on a donc à vous
êtes un homme du Sud-Ouest
ils adorent leur aiguille on regarde la
lune de la revue politique et
parlementaire Arnaud
c'est politique des liaisons
tumultueuses
pour 130 ans d'existence avec un sujet
qui est très large c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire notamment on parle de la
question de l'évolution du vote des
femmes des comportements électoraux et
il y a un article qui montre que
finalement ce qui parle passé finalement
définissait une sorte de différence
entre le vote masculin et le vote
féminin n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire dans la revue politique et
parlementaire
sont des hommes comme les autres
et merci Quentin merci à tous de nous
avoir suivis pour voir ou avoir cette
émission c'est sur notre nouvelle
plateforme public sénat.fr on se
retrouve lundi on vous souhaite un très
bon weekend
[Musique]